yeah there's some my sister and my
brother were actually okay i was not you
know i think we mentioned this before
but i moved out of hollywood and to the
outskirts of hollywood to kind of uh get
her away from
hollywood in a bad crowd and the crowd
that we moved into there's been maybe
three big movies made out of one of them
being what's the justin timberlake movie
called alpha dog alpha dog oh that's
that was you that was like your school
that was her kids
uh 13.
13 reasons that's something i forget was
called the nick cassavetes movie yeah
but it was a mess those kids were a mess
the the bling ring i was friends with
nick cassavete's daughter that's what
yeah yeah yeah i mean there's messed up
kids messed up you have no idea you have
no idea how i would come home from a gig
or early and i'd have to we'd have to go
find her and i'd go break into a party
and pull her out she hated me and all
her friends hated me and it was not fun
and i was not cool and it was not cool
being howie mandel's daughter i don't
think it's do you want kids uh it
doesn't come up my therapist was like do
you want kids i'm like i don't know and
she goes in seven years of therapy
you've never once mentioned children so
that means no yeah you don't have to i'm
fine if it happened i've got money i
could deal with it
that's so emotionally attached yeah
that's an attachment i got a dog during
the pandemic and that's enough that's
enough fatherhood for me yeah are you in
a relationship now uh
in between
in between right yeah and are you going
to have to explain to somebody after
this that i i refer to you as the in
between
i'm
like literally it's like i'm hours out
of a conversation of ending one and
i'm have a date tonight so we'll uh wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
that's hysterical
you you you just you have a date tonight
yet somebody has just been alerted that
it's the end of it was it was something
that kind of ended and then they found
out about this new person and we had to
have a talk
uh but i'm it's i'm pretty casual with
things is it somebody we know
you don't have to tell me but just tell
me if it's somebody we know you may have
no one famous oh but cause you've gone
out with famous people
amy yes uh ten years ago uh didn't
didn't enjoy it uh but prefer prefers
civilians to be quite honest um but did
she know you didn't enjoy it have you
said that publicly amy yeah oh yeah i
don't know publicly i i mean i enjoyed
dating amy but when the thing when fame
got in there it was just it was just got
messy um for both of us we kind of both
blew up at the same time uh but yeah
this new this new one i think you've met
her
but uh
but not for a while did it end because
you started seeing the other girl that
you're going on a date with like you're
like oh i like this one better so i'm
gonna end it with this one no one and i
shouldn't be saying any of this [ __ ] but
uh but one was kind of like a very much
a product of the uh pandemic where we
kind of were both doing it alone and
just decided to kind of like team up and
get through it and as the pandemic ended
it just kind of we kind of drifted apart
is this what are we are you reiterating
the conversation that was had hours ago
a little bit okay a little bit
yeah is that what you explained this was
just about the pandemic and we needed
each other and now that we're insane
like that and i was like i still care
about you want to be friends but i also
have to kind of move on with my life
right and you said to her i will love
you till the delta variant
yeah and then until i come up with
something else because now i want
something new it was a lot of like
trying to convince her that this new
girl had nothing to do with it and i
believe that but it's tough to convince
someone of that but at your age and with
your track record you're not going to
settle down though right i i think if i
if i was going to i would have by now
that i i can that's what i think like i
could see maybe like a you know an
untraditional partnership down the line
where we're just kind of like we kind of
want to leave each other alone and we
live in the same house and and uh do
things together but i'm very happy being
single we live in the same house we love
being together
there's this whole new movement about
not like even if you're married not
sleeping in the same bedroom which i'm
not saying anything about my
relationship we're pretty conventional
but there's this whole movement that
like why are you supposed to even stay
in the same bedroom like why don't
people have separate bedrooms because
you're supposed to have your separate
space and why is that a weird thing so
you can have something like that where
you just but that's roommates that's not
a no it doesn't have to be i always say
that i would rather be lonely than
annoyed and i've just gotten annoyed in
almost every relationship i've been in
at some point and i'm very i i always
say i get into one fight at the end
and then that's it but it's it's usually
like a very it builds up congenial
jovial yeah yeah i guess it's just you
just i don't have the practice of
dealing with little problems i love that
your breakups are congenial and jovial
but you're uh
dark and appointed oh yeah are you an
only child oldest of five oh what was
your theory i mean he gets annoyed
easily at other people i just he lived
with he lived with four other people
maybe that's why maybe put on this earth
to annoy him yeah yeah i was annoyed i
was annoyed until i got to leave for
college you're the oldest
what's the rate you're in your 40s right
you're familiar yeah 42 and then it's
like my sister yummy is 40. uh the
youngest is my brother it was me three
girls and a brother he's seven years
younger so he just turned 35 uh five or
six months ago right and they all i
don't know that they all but i just
listen to your act they they are some of
them are married with kids
my sister is married with kids nothing
in my act is true none of that like i i
i like kill my parents every hour
and resurrect them for the next hour
grandparents are coming and going
sisters are dying uh yeah nothing when
they hear these things and they're
part of these made-up stories does that
bother them no they love it because they
know it's made up so they can be okay
but my mom will say i'll have a joke
about my mom my parents have been
together
now almost 50 years happily married me
too and uh
and uh and i'll be like so my mom was
having an affair and people will stop
her on the street and be like i didn't
know you were having an affair
those jokes aren't true but it sounds
like it the premises all sound true even
if the punchline's not
[Music]